it is now my distinct pleasure to
introduce our keynote speaker business
leader investment icon philanthropist
business school alum University trustee
and Carnegie Mellon champion David Allen
pepper
oh I have several pages to read David
through his legendary business savvy and
investment expertise Davis David has
earned an unrivaled reputation as one of
the most successful hedge fund managers
in the world but he's equally well known
for his passion for philanthropy his
belief in the power of higher education
and of course his exceptional service
and generosity to his alma mater
Carnegie Mellon University David grew up
not too far from here in the Stanton
Heights neighborhood of Pittsburgh
the middle of three children I should
just add so that David's mother Roberta
is here with us
would you please acknowledge Roberta
he went to the University of Pittsburgh
for his undergraduate degree in
economics before receiving his MBA in
1982 from our graduate school of
industrial administration it wasn't
called at upper school back there I know
in 1985 he was recruited by Goldman
Sachs as a credit analyst and within
just six months he became the head
trader under newly established
high-yield bond group this was the first
clue that David was a force to be
reckoned with on Wall Street in 1993 the
same year the web entered the public
domain
David established Appaloosa management
and over the last 25 years has built an
impressively consistent record of high
returns Appaloosa currently has
approximately 17 billion under
management and has yielded gross returns
close to 40 percent per year
over the past 20 years through the David
Tepper Charitable Foundation his
philanthropy has expanded opportunities
for education helped to fight hunger and
homelessness and provided much-needed
disaster relief he has generously
donated a total of 125 million to
Carnegie Mellon University
including naming and endowing The Temper
School of Business where he serves as
the school's Business Board of Advisors
and in 2013 his most recent
transformative gift enabled the creation
of his state of the art facility on the
new David a Tepper quadrangle scheduled
to open this fall at at more than 300
thousand square feet this building will
serve as the new home for the Tempur
School of Business as well as a major
hub for collaboration innovation
creativity and entrepreneurship at
Carnegie Mellon The Temper quad will
create unprecedented opportunities to
break new barriers and to work toward
new discoveries new technologies new
businesses and new forms of expression
as our institution continues to grow and
build for an evolving future the Tempur
quad is the physical realization of a
new model for 21st century research and
education and it will transform the CMU
experience for generations of students
to come David has given so much to
Carnegie Mellon to our nation and the
world and were delighted to welcome him
back to campus to share his wisdom with
the class of 2018 please join me in
extending a warm welcome to David a
tapper David
good morning class of 2018 and I have a
speech here nice binder I think I might
read it later but I just a couple
observations first that I didn't think
about before back over there I was
standing next to Kevin he's right there
and we were talking his voice was
shaking my voice was shaking we were
both nervous as heck I was gonna say
another word but I'm told I'm not
supposed to say those words today so
we're coming out and we're we're there
and we're both kind of like shaky a
little bit and then Kevin Kevin start
straightening up he starts getting the
strength about it and he says I'm
starting to fill it these are my people
my people so we say that he's put it out
some friends over there we said hottest
family over there his mother Lauren who
told me a couple stories about Kevin
that I'm not gonna say now went up the
aisle shaked a few hands there set a
load of an wall high n wall yeah good to
see you over there and you know Kevin
just came up here and gave the most
fantastic speech and I'm thinking crap I
can't not be as good cuz I got something
I got a reading it's twice as long and I
can't just kind of ad-lib it and then I
was thinking well you know what you guys
Kevin's family you guys out here
students please all you guys here you're
my people too okay you're my people too
you're Carnegie Mellon people Carnegie
Mellon students Carnegie Mellon
graduates my people so help me out today
I need help
so because I got to read this and I
don't know how it's gonna go so we're
gonna see all right let me start by
thank you for him for that kind
introduction for the kind introduction I
got to get this kind of right here I
don't know what I'm gonna do after his
leadership at Carnegie Mellon as you
know for him this place means the world
to me
it really is a treasure there's no other
University that brings together business
where are you
thank you the arts
the humanities the sciences and the
social sciences the way CMU does good to
see you thanks also to my fellow
trustees to my fellow alumni who are
over the place here engineering
I apologized they told me not to leave
the podium but I don't I'm sorry about
that
and engineering can I get a hardhat up
here this big all right
I cannot lost my place but what's right
thanks also to my fellow trustees my
fellow alumni and most of all to you
guys whose students and to your parents
a special thanks to my family and
friends who are here today and of course
to my 86 year old mom I think she's over
there hi mom when you're over there
someplace mom where are you mom
someplace over there I think my mom's a
little happy and proud today but my mom
sometimes can be a pain in the butt and
I'm sure your parents can be too but
there is nobody on earth I owe more to
and there's nobody on earth you owe more
to than your parents in life in life you
should recognize your parents so let's
take a moment and thank them
and last but not least I want to
congratulate and thank my fellow
honorary doctors adda
where are you at it that is a very funny
lady I got to tell you this whoever's
gonna listen to her later a Nobel Prize
what she also has a Nobel Prize
it's a side thing Shafi Goldwasser a
touring Award winner and a guy used to
watch on TV when I was younger not that
much younger an Emmy Award winner Ted
Danson they're catching up to your wife
dead his wife has a couple doctors more
than him so but he's catching up now
it's amazing what you can find out by
talking to people it's a good thing to
listen now after the thank you so I
think I'm supposed to start a speech
here and preparing I was given advice
from professional speech writers and
public relations people and of course my
children they all told me not to be too
controversial and try to be proper
let me apologize to all of them in
advance sorry guys not gonna happen I
also prepared by listening some of the
best commencement speeches of all time
many were by actors somewhere by
politicians all were delivered with
eloquence and in a professional manner
to all those of attendance to all those
in attendance if you were expecting to
hear a professional speech today you may
be at the wrong commencement but what I
can't promise what I can't promise you
is as much honesty and personal personal
life experiences as I can muster I think
people's life's are really combination
of different lace for you students it's
been a life you had before college with
your parents and the life you had at
college now
and the life you're about to embark on
I'm sure some of you I'm sure some of
you have overcome incredible adversity
all of you have had and I can promise
you all have challenges disappointments
and triumphs I'm no different on the
trunk trial side this has been a hell of
a week a kid from the streets of
Pittsburgh who had to work his way
through college at Pitt and grad school
or Treat CMU just got an honorary Doctor
and it's giving MSO Swedish at this
university a kid a kid who could afford
to go to an NFL game
I kissed
a kid who sorry about that a kid who
can't afford to go to an NFL game until
well went to his 20s is on the verge of
getting the NFL's approval to buy the
Carolina Panthers not too shabby
but believe me it did start out that way
I grew up I grew up in a working-class
neighborhood to stand the heights in the
city of Pittsburgh we played touch
football on the street and tackle
football in a nearby cemetery we try to
not hit the gravestones the cell phone
of the day was mom calling up the street
to say dinner was ready my dad like a
lot of dads had to work 60 hours weeks
just to make ends meet but he taught me
a couple of things a couple important
lessons first always think about charity
and those less fortunate
he came even when my family didn't have
enough and another lesson he used to ask
us who do you treat better the president
or the garbage man do you guys know the
answer
garbage man I'm talking just generally
not about any specific president by the
way
garbage man garbage man is garbage man
maybe the right answer because somebody
just got to take your trash everyday
right and if he doesn't take your trash
sure really trouble but actually the
answer is you treat them both both the
same all men and women and women deserve
to be treated equally and with respect
[Applause]
despite these good things about my dad
he had a bad side too he was physically
abusive to me I'm sure it was a cycle
that he got from his father and his
father got from his father if my young
life
there was nothing more terrifying there
was no greater adversity but I prayed to
God that I would never be the same to my
children and I'm proud to say and what I
view as the greatest accomplishment of
my life I broke that cycle
thank you now I'm shaking high school
was at an inner-city school called
Peabody was about half white and half
african-american there really was a lot
of tension at the school between us at
the school back then and between the
different high schools things were so
bad between Westinghouse high school and
Peabody I think it's now called a Barack
Obama high that when we played each
other in football it was in front of
empty stands to keep people from
fighting it was rough there was actually
no grass on the field it was dirt rocks
and they used to oil down the field to
keep the dust from coming up true story
one field goal post was against the
skull the other field goal post was
against a fence if you ran out of the
endzone you had real problems so I
played a little football in high school
when I was also in school place CFA but
money being short I had to work my first
job application was at McDonald's I got
turned down I did I think it was because
I had an oversize afro wouldn't be a
problem today actually wanted to take
that off was so frickin hot up here I
gotta tell you
but I did get a job as a short-order
cook in a deli I also sold knife
door-to-door and it was a union work in
a bakery after high school I went to the
University of Pittsburgh where's it down
there okay where I ate at the dirty Oh
the original hotdog anybody original
hotdog France if you like the French
fries better you like the hotdogs better
french fries raise your head hot dogs
all right
transfer eyes win the day maybe the
dirty Oh had a girlfriend or two and
worked at the Fine Arts Library and got
an honours degree in economics
after Pitt I worked at a bank for a
little and then came to Koenig Negi
Mellon for my MBA even though his hard
work I actually loved this place it was
also the foundation for everything I've
done professionally since then this paid
place this place gave me the tools I
needed to be successful it really did
I'm not kidding well when I graduated I
kind of liked markets and investments so
I tried to get a job with Goldman Sachs
but they rejected me didn't get a job
there we'll come back to goldman sachs a
little later so after I got my MBA I
made an unusual choice at the time I
went to work for Republic Steel that
wasn't a great time for steel but I know
I would have be exposed to a lot and I
really wanted to learn about three
months after I got the Republic still
they gave a seven percent
across-the-board
pay cut pay cut all my business gold
buddies oh my gosh business school
friends called me up and said great
choice Thep in two years we probably
still had to merge to avoid bankruptcy
but it was a great choice and in those
two years as they were trying to save
the company we did more finance skills
than it had at its previous 100 year
history and I learned from each one of
them there's a lesson here in life in
life get all the experience you can
while you're young go for the experience
versus a paycheck that kind of
experience got me a job at a mutual fund
specializing to distressed companies and
eventually in the door of Goldman Sachs
we're in a short time because my
previous job experience and Kutta gets
things
cutting edge things I learned at CMU I
advanced quickly and became the head
trader and Goldman's junk desk that gave
me more status and I knew at the time
but I really wanted was to become a
partner I was up a partner for a few
times but never made it one of the
reasons was I had to refuse a powerful
partners request the stories this the
partner has started a new fund to invest
in bankrupt companies and I was supposed
to make the trades for him he was also
the partner who controlled our
restricted list that's the list of
companies where you might have some
conflicts are some sensitive information
he asked me to buy a company that he had
just removed from the restricted list
that day that day it didn't seem right
in fact I went to our legal department
had told them what was going on they
said it would be okay after a lot of
back and forth but it still didn't feel
right to me so I refused again I didn't
get fired but when I came up for partner
I got shot down and I was incredibly
upset but you know what you know what it
turned out all right
because I didn't end up a partner at
Goldman Sachs I started started my own
company 25 years ago in 1993 called
Appaloosa and ended up doing something
that was a lot more fun and made my life
better in so many ways in life in life
do what's right really do what's right
and it won't hurt you
just keep your priorities straight you
know I keep saying in life but really as
I said before there are many lies I've
had an incredible life from humble
beginnings I've raised three great kids
have a woman I love I've had a
successful business career and
incredible philanthropic endeavors and
now I am speaking to you as a newly
named doctorate and I am on the verge of
being named an NFL owner
you guys you guys used to this is okay
to say guys do this girls carry guys
that are just guys girls whatever you
students sorry you had a life with your
parents then a life at CMU and you're
going to have a few more lifes right now
like I did I think I'll right now you
all have negative balance sheets but you
have so much upside you all have great
opportunities ahead
don't let anyone anyone tell you
different you live in what was is and
always will be the land of opportunity
and that most and the greatest and most
generous country in the world remember
remember this last thing when all you
become successful remember to give back
give back god bless all you god bless
see em you and god bless america
thank you
you